bonjour et bienvenue sur my force alors
les maths à quoi ça sert je pense que
c'est une question qu'on sait vraiment
où se posait souvent à la fin d'un long
cours très ennuyeux de mathématiques
parfois même au début de ce corps et
c'est une question quand on y réfléchit
un petit peu qui est en fait presque des
villes tellement en fait il ya un nombre
monstrueux d'applications dans les
mathématiques les mathématiques sont
vraiment partout dans notre vie
quotidienne dans nos smartphones dans
nos ordinateurs dans le web niveau tout
ce qui est réseau nous vos réseaux
énergétiques non de l'énergie plus
généralement tout ce qui est
optimisation tout ce qui est
planification si vous avez des horaires
des bus qui sont calculées et ils ont
été calculés à l'aide d'outils
mathématiques tout ce qui est niveau
marketing ciblage publicitaire ski et
détection de tendances comprend sont des
clients tout ce qui est tarification
vaches et les mathématiques aujourd'hui
sont absolument partout partout partout
sont partout bien souvent mon industrie
mais elles sont également partout dans
le monde de la recherche
si vous voulez faire aujourd'hui de la
recherche en pharmacologie ou en
génétique ou en épidémiologie ou en
chimie psychologie en histoire en
géographie bien sûr en physique et en
mathématiques partout aujourd'hui vous
avez besoin de mathématiques et
l'utilité des mathématiques dans des
matières où a priori elles sont pas
forcément utiles comme l'économie ou la
psychologie où l'histoire se trouve être
redoutablement efficace pour nous donner
des nouvelles compréhension vu que les
deux approches pour comprendre ces
domaines les mathématiques sont vraiment
vraiment partout aujourd'hui
cependant quand on apprend les
mathématiques et qu'on se demande à quoi
ça sert de mathématiques et en se dotant
en fait à quoi ça va me servir que théo
cas quoi cela peut servir dans la
société en général
s'ils ont envie d'avoir un boulot un peu
classique et bien c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
bouleaux classique
les gens ne font pas de mathématiques du
coup à quoi ça peut servir les
mathématiques là je pense qu'en fait
tout ce que j'ai à dire est assez
anecdotique comparé aux vrais intérêts
des mathématiques
qui est un intérêt éducatif je pense que
si les mathématiques ont un poids aussi
importante dans l'éducation c'est pas du
tout un hasard
en particulier les mathématiques c'est
quand même le domaine de prédilection de
l'abstraction cette capacité d'oublier
un maximum de détails de la réalité pour
se concentrer sur un concept clé un
phénomène clé qui va souvent expliqué de
plein de choses dans la société ou dans
notre monde quotidien les mathématiques
aussi c'est un domaine où la rigueur
pour une place de choix puisque en
mathématiques
on a une exigence de rigueur bien
supérieur à la plupart des autres de
matières en tout cas tel que c'est
enseigner à l'école je sais que lorsque
l'on fait de la recherche à très haut
niveau que ce soit en histoire où et
n'importe quel domaine
à ce moment le niveau de rigueur est
très très élevé finalement est plus tout
cas bien plus super que celui qui nous
était imposé à l'école donc j'ai pas du
tout envie de vous dire que les
mathématiques sont la seule matière où
l'on apprend la rigueur mais il me
semble qu'au niveau de l'école c'est la
matière où on demande de plus de rigueur
aux élèves enfin les mathématiques c'est
aussi et surtout à mon sens un domaine
de créativité ça peut surprendre pas mal
d'entre vous ce n'est pas fait de
mathématiques en études supérieures mais
je pense que les mathématiques c'est
même le domaine de prédilection pour
développer une véritable créativité
parce qu'en fait quand on veut vendre
des mathématiques mais parce qu'on va
devoir chercher à faire c'est développer
ses propres manières de penser trouver
des nouvelles astuces
vraiment il ya un aspect créatif qui
plus est très important dans les
mathématiques et donc une petite
histoire ce sujet par david gilberte qui
disait de l'un de ses étudiants
il a arrêté les mathématiques car il
n'était pas assez créatif maintenant il
fait de la poésie et tout va bien pour
lui sous-entendu la poésie est beaucoup
moins créative que les mathématiques
encore une fois séparé cherche à vous
montrer que c'est vrai parce que ce soit
si c'est vrai mais il me semble que
gilbert plus le croyez vraiment et que
selon ce très très grands mathématiciens
l'ingrédient principal qui fait qu'une
personne va être bonne en mathématiques
c'est la créativité et d'ailleurs je
dirais même jusqu'à dire que
si des disciplines comme les sciences
sociales se sont mathématisée ces
dernières années et simon gagné a
traumatisé bon c'est d'une part grâce à
la rigueur
la quantification et l'abstraction que
permettent les mathématiques mais je
pense aussi que ces disciplines beaucoup
gagné à être mathématisée notamment
parce que ce faisant elles ont attiré
beaucoup de mathématiciens qui ont
apporté une nouvelle façon de comprendre
un aspect créatif une nouvelle façon de
faire qui a permis de faire de grandes
avancées dans ses autres disciplines
étudiées à des avancées qui sont
orthogonale dans une direction opposée à
celle qui avait été fait dans le passé
et donc de rajouter vraiment des quelque
chose de nouveau
je pense que les mathématiques si elles
sont bien enseigner doit pouvoir
enseigner cette créativité mathématiques
qui est le ski le plus important en fait
à mon sens que l'on apprend quand on
apprend à faire des mathématiques
enfin ça c'est toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles je pense que ça vaut le cloud
apprendre les mathématiques à l'école
mais si on veut être un petit peu
pratique et pragmatique et réaliste faut
bien avouer que l'intérêt principal des
mathématiques aujourd'hui c'est dans la
société c'est la sélection l'espèce des
lic
j'aime pas forcément ce terme je dirais
que malheureusement les mathématiques
ont été instrumentalisés pour
sélectionner la classe dirigeante
on peut trouver des raisons à cela je
pense que le fait que les mathématiques
sont est une discipline qui soit facile
à noter et où finalement un classement
assez régulier d'un contrôle à l'autre
le classement dans la classe en
automatique va pas trop être bouleversé
je pense que ça ça permet de légitimiser
la sélection par la plupart des
mathématiques par rapport aux buts par
opposition à une autre matière où il
aurait plus de variations dans les notes
pense que c'est peut-être une raison qui
pourrait peut-être permettre de
légitimiser les mathématiques comme
matière de sélection mais en tant que
bulgari thater mathématicien jusqu'où
certains crabe le mans dommage que les
mathématiques ont été instrumentalisés
de la sorte puisque ça a conduit au fait
que tous ceux qui n'ont pas su ce qu'ils
n'ont pas réussi à travers cette voie à
l'école se trouve
frustré par les mathématiques et voire
anéanti par les mathématiques
est ce le fait que les mathématiques
soit la matière de la sélection est ce
qui a été préjudiciable à l'appréciation
des mathématiques par le grand public
à mon sens donc c'est là quelque chose
que je regrette quand même fortement
cette sélection par de mathématiques
même si moi d'un peu de personnages bien
sûr j'en ai profité puisque comme vous
l'imaginez n'était pas trop mauvais en
mathématiques à l'école et que ça m'a
permis de me démarquer
donc là je pense qu'on a pas mal lister
toutes les raisons classiques qui sont
avancés pour lesquels les mathématiques
serait utile simon avoue du moins à la
société en général
ceci dit je pense qu'il ya une
quatrième raison qui est la plus
importante pour moi qui explique
pourquoi les mathématiques sont utiles
et c'est la suivante je pense que les
mathématiques sont très utiles pour
rendre heureux j'espère que vous l'avez
senti moi ça me fait vraiment plaisir de
faire des mathématiques j'adore ça c'est
ce que c'est vraiment un kif et j'espère
avoir pas mal partager ça avec vous et
quand je vois vos commentaires dans mes
vidéos je vous dis que vous vous si vous
êtes en train de faire des mathématiques
en me regardant existants réfléchissons
alors bien sûr c'est pas forcément avec
des équations mathématiques c'est pas
forcément avec des équations et jusque
le fait que vous faites des efforts de
réflexion pour moi ce cd mathématiques
nous fait et ça me fait super plaisir de
voir que vous preniez plaisir à penser
les mathématiques ça c'est mon plus
grand kiff plus encore que de faire des
mathématiques c'est de voir les gens ont
apprécié faire des mathématiques
d'abord mon truc préféré moi j'adore
faire des vidéos avec vous j'adore mon
truc vraiment préféré un grand grand
kiff
c'est plus de faire des présentations
live des conférences données des
séminaires de mathématiques notamment à
des publics qui s'attendent pas
forcément va aimer le séminaire que je
venais ou les mathématiques en général
et puis un peu retourné leur vision des
mathématiques en direct ça c'est mon
plus grand kiff j'ai fait ce à quelques
reprises et j'adore voir les gens
sourire et prendre plaisir à faire des
mathématiques et je rajoute que je pense
vraiment que tout le monde peut se faire
plaisir en faisant des mathématiques
faut vraiment se sortir de l'esprit
l'idée selon laquelle les mathématiques
sont en matière de sélection et que du
coup on va être jugés sur notre niveau
mathématique il faut vraiment se dire
qu'on va faire des maths et
mathématiques uniquement pour essayer de
trouver du bonheur du plaisir à penser
les mathématiques et à ce moment là
vraiment je pense que tout le monde peut
se faire plaisir en faisant des
mathématiques
donc voilà plus grande utilité pour moi
des mathématiques c'est à rendre heureux
et quand on voit aujourd'hui l'actualité
des jt ou des journaux qui a pas
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui
permettent de se rendre heureux du coup
vraiment une mathématique c'est pour moi
un truc très important juste pour que
pour profiter un peu de notre passage
sur terre les mathématiques sont
vraiment une façon de profiter de ce
passage le testing de notre vie et de me
rendre heureux qu'ils aient vraiment
pour moi l'objectif le plus important
finalement de la vie si pour moi c'est à
ça que ça sert de plus les mathématiques
mais c'est ma force m ça vaut ce que ça
vaut est votre avis compte au moins
autant que le mien donc vous invite à le
mettre dans le commentaire